Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Bonjour mes amis et bienvenue au Rest is History avec moi Dominique Sandroek et mon ami Tom Hollande Tom, that was some beautiful French That was wonderful We are, well we say it every time don't we
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、提前获取节目系列，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Bonjour mes amis et bienvenue au Rest is History，我是多米尼克·桑德鲁克，还有我的朋友汤姆·霍兰。汤姆，刚才那段法语真优美。太棒了。我们，呃，我们每次都这么说，不是吗？
we're in the middle of our World Cup marathon I'm actually sick of saying it We are in the middle of our World Cup marathon. I'm actually sick of saying it. We are in the middle of our World Cup marathon. So say something else. We don't know what order they'll be put out in. It could be at the beginning, couldn't it? Yeah. Or it could be at the end.
我们正处于世界杯马拉松节目的中间。其实我都说腻了。我们正处于世界杯马拉松节目的中间。我其实说腻了。我们正处于世界杯马拉松节目的中间。那就说点别的。我们不知道这些节目会以什么顺序发布。这可能是开头，对吧？对。或者也可能是结尾。
But who knows? That's the jeopardy. It's the World Cup. We're doing a series of podcasts about the history of the competing countries, choosing sort of slightly offbeat subjects sometimes. And we come to France. Now, Tom, a few weeks ago, we did an absolutely, even if I say so myself,
但谁知道呢？这就是刺激的地方。这就是世界杯。我们正在做一系列关于参赛国历史的播客，有时会选择一些稍微有点冷门的题材。然后我们来到了法国。现在，汤姆，几个星期前，我们做了一期绝对堪称精彩绝伦的节目——即使由我自己来说——
an absolutely magnificent podcast about French history through film with the French critic Muriel Zaga. And it was brilliant, not because of anything. It was magnifique. It was magnifique. It was super. It was extra.
这是一期关于法国电影史的绝对精彩的播客，嘉宾是法国影评人穆里尔·扎加（Muriel Zaga）。而且节目非常棒，并不是因为别的。太美妙了。太美妙了。太棒了。太绝了。
And that wasn't because of anything you and I contributed at all. It was because she was brilliant. And so if you haven't listened to that, go back and listen to that. If you have listened to that, keep listening, because Tom is going to – Tom, are you going to do the whole podcast in a French accent or not? No, no.
这并不是因为你和我有什么贡献。完全是因为她太优秀了。所以如果你还没听过那一期，回去听听吧。如果你听过了，那就继续听下去，因为汤姆要——汤姆，你打算用整段法语口音来做这期播客吗？还是不？不，不。
No, I'm not. I'm going to keep it very British, because actually the subject today does have a British angle and, indeed, an American angle. And, indeed, it has a to uh the theme of the podcast that you were talking about which is a film because uh today's subject is um louis amy augustin le prince who i think can legitimately be described as the father of cine film, of moving film, moving camera. Oh, nice. And it's a very interesting and ultimately rather tragic and mysterious story. That's how we like them.
不，我不会。我会保持非常英式的口音，因为事实上，今天的主题确实带有一个英国视角，当然，也有一个美国视角。而且，它还包含了一个——呃——你刚才谈到的播客主题，也就是电影，因为——呃——今天的主题是——嗯——路易·艾米·奥古斯丁·勒普兰斯（Louis Aimé Augustin Le Prince），我认为他完全可以被称为电影胶片之父、移动电影之父、动态摄像机之父。哦，不错。这是一个非常有趣、而且最终相当悲惨且神秘的故事。这正是我们喜欢的风格。
Have you ever heard of Louis Leprince? I'll be honest with you. The only time I've ever heard of him is when you told me you were going to do a podcast. Okay. And I deliberately not informed myself, Tom, so that I can have the pleasure of learning at the feet of the master. Okay. So Louis Le Prince, he's born in 1841 in Metz. And Metz is, you know, it's on the eastern flank of France. And so it's not surprised perhaps that Louis Lebrun's father is in the artillery. So it's a kind of military station. He's a major. But I think more significantly for our story,
你听说过路易·勒普兰斯吗？老实说，我唯一一次听说他，还是你告诉我你要做一期关于他的播客时。好吧。而且我故意没有去做功课，汤姆，这样我才能享受在宗师脚下聆听教诲的快乐。好吧。所以，路易·勒普兰斯于1841年出生在梅斯（Metz）。梅斯呢，你知道的，它位于法国的东翼。所以，路易·勒普兰斯的父亲在炮兵部队服役，或许也就不足为奇了。所以这算是一个军事驻地。他是一名少校。但我想，对于我们的故事来说，更重要的是，
Dominic, he is a friend of Louis Daguerre, as in the inventor of the Daguerreotype. And in fact, taker of the first ever photograph of a person because the exposure when daguerre was taking his photographs it had to last for several minutes so you know traffic's going too fast for that but he takes a photograph in 1838 of a street in paris where there is a man having his boots blacked so there's the man himself and the boot black. And these are the two first people ever to be photographed. So for young Louis, very exciting to be in association with Louis Daguerre. Yeah. And Daguerre teaches Le Prince chemistry and photography.
多米尼克，他是路易·达盖尔（Louis Daguerre）的朋友，也就是达盖尔摄影法（Daguerreotype）的发明者。事实上，他也是人类历史上第一张人物照片的拍摄者，因为当年达盖尔拍照时的曝光时间需要长达好几分钟——所以，你知道的，街上的交通太快了，拍不下来——但他于1838年拍摄了一张巴黎街头的照片，里面有一个正在擦皮鞋的人。所以照片里有这个人本人，还有擦鞋匠。这是人类历史上仅有的前两个被拍进照片里的人。所以对于年轻的路易来说，能与路易·达盖尔结识，是一件非常令人兴奋的事。是的。达盖尔教给勒普兰斯化学和摄影知识。
And that's a reflection of the fact that Le Prince, unlike you, Dominic, he he's interested very interested in the arts but he's also interested in science and it's that is a difference so he he has a very very artistic temperament but he also has a very very keen interest in uh in science and the practical applications of science i only have one of those things tom i know you do i know i know so that is why the likelihood of you making a radical invention in the field of cinematography is limited i would say yeah unlikely louis goes on to study uh painting in paris and then he goes to leipzig as a postgraduate where he studies chemistry and while he's at leipzig he meets up with uh an englishman called john robin whitley and whitley the, he's the eldest son of a guy in Leeds who owns an iron foundry. And he's called Joseph Whitley. So this, LaPrance's new friend, John Robin Whitley,
这也反映出一个事实：勒普兰斯不像你，多米尼克，他对艺术非常感兴趣，但也对科学非常感兴趣。这就是区别。所以他有着非常非常艺术化的气质，但同时也对科学以及科学的实际应用有着非常非常浓厚的兴趣。汤姆，我只有其中一样。我知道你有，我懂，我懂。所以这就是为什么你在电影摄影领域做出重大发明的可能性非常有限，我想说。是的，不太可能。路易接着去巴黎学习绘画，然后作为研究生去了莱比锡（Leipzig）学习化学。在莱比锡期间，他结识了一位名叫约翰·罗宾·惠特利（John Robin Whitley）的英国人。惠特利是利兹一位拥有铁厂的老板的长子。他叫约瑟夫·惠特利（Joseph Whitley）。所以，勒普兰斯的新朋友约翰·罗宾·惠特利，
he's a product of the industrial revolution in Victorian Britain. And they get on tremendously well. Le Prince, I think, he seems to be a very lovable figure. He's a large kind of bear of a man, very gentle, so kind of gentle giant, much admired for his brilliance and for his kindness. So a very nice man. Sounds great. I would say of all the people perhaps that we've discussed on our podcast, he seems to be the nicest so far that is a big claim tom that is a big claim but i can't think of anyone who's nicer in the episode on the costas reek and civil war you have two characters don pepe and dr valverde i think he's nicer than both of them crikey that is i never thought i'd hear those words anyway so
他是维多利亚时代英国工业革命的产物。他们俩相处得极其融洽。我觉得勒普兰斯似乎是一个非常讨人喜欢的人物。他身材高大，像一头温和的熊，非常温和，可以说是一个温和的巨人，因其才华和善良而备受推崇。所以是一个非常好的人。听起来很棒。我想说，在我们播客讨论过的所有人当中，他似乎是迄今为止最好的人。汤姆，这可真是个惊人的评价。这确实是个惊人的评价，但我实在想不出谁比他更好了。在讲哥斯达黎加内战那一集里，你有两个角色，堂·佩佩（Don Pepe）和瓦尔韦德医生（Dr. Valverde），我觉得他比这两位都要好。天哪，我从没想过会听到这样的话。不管怎样，所以——
it will not surprise you bearing in mind mind how nice Louis Le Prince is, that John Robin Whitley, the son of a Leeds industrialist, invites him to come to Leeds and to visit him. And so Le Prince goes in 1867, and he joins Joseph Whitley's firm. And two years later, Dominic, in 1869, he marries whitley's sister elizabeth who like le prince i actually very like him he's she's um a very talented artist and she's very interested in photography so again there's that that kind of fusion that you no offense completely laugh that fusion of artistic brilliance and fascination with technology. I could not have married that woman, Tom. You could have done.
考虑到路易·勒普兰斯人有多好，利兹工业家的儿子约翰·罗宾·惠特利邀请他来利兹做客，你一定不会感到意外。于是勒普兰斯在1867年去了那里，并加入了约瑟夫·惠特利的公司。两年后，多米尼克，在1869年，他娶了惠特利的妹妹伊丽莎白（Elizabeth）。伊丽莎白和勒普兰斯一样——我其实非常喜欢她——她是一位非常有才华的艺术家，对摄影也非常感兴趣。所以，再次体现了那种融合——毫无恶意，完全是开玩笑——那种艺术才华与对科技迷恋的融合。汤姆，我可娶不了那样坚韧的女性。你本来可以的，
I'm sorry to say. You could have done, but it wouldn't have been as much of a marriage of equals as was the case with Louis and Elizabeth. And they got on tremendously well. They set up a school of applied arts in Leeds. It's incredibly successful. Their particular gimmick is that they take photographs and they fix it onto uh kind of metal and pots and pans and all kinds of things they fix photographs to pots pans yeah so you you kind of project it onto the pots and pans okay well so photographic images onto metal that's
我很遗憾地说。你本来可以的，但这不会像路易和伊丽莎白那样成为一场势均力敌的婚姻。他们俩相处得极其融洽。他们在利兹创办了一所应用艺术学校。它取得了巨大的成功。他们的特门技术是，他们将照片拍摄并固定在——某种金属、锅碗瓢盆以及各种各样的东西上，他们把照片固定在锅碗瓢盆上。锅碗瓢盆，是的。所以你会把照片投影到锅碗瓢盆上面。好吧，把摄影图像印在金属上，这就是——
that's their gimmick um but they also specialize in portraits so So they take a portrait of Gladstone, for instance, and they take a portrait of Queen Victoria. Golly. And the measure of their renown is that in 1878, when Cleopatra's Needle gets set up on the bank of the Thames, so Cleopatra's Needle is an obelisk that's been brought from Egypt. It's still there to this day, reputedly cursed. Before they set it up, they put a underneath you know in the foundations where it's going to be
这就是他们的绝活儿。嗯，但他们也专精于肖像画。所以，例如，他们为格莱斯顿（Gladstone）拍摄了肖像，也为维多利亚女王拍摄了肖像。天哪。他们声誉的一个衡量标准是，在1878年，当克利奥帕特拉针（Cleopatra's Needle，即埃及方尖碑）在泰晤士河畔竖立起来时——克利奥帕特拉针是从埃及运来的一座方尖碑。它至今仍矗立在那里，据传受到了诅咒。在竖立它之前，他们把一些东西放在了——你知道的——即将竖立它的地基下面，
erected and there is uh there are there's a rupee is put there a railway guide a copy of whittaker's almanac a baby's bottle various other things um photographs of england's 12 greatest beauties and a photograph taken by Louis and Sarah of Queen Victoria. And it goes in there. I do like a time capsule, Tom. They've gone out of fashion now, haven't they? They have. But they're great things. Yeah. And Louis and Sarah are very much a part of it, this exciting time capsule world. Yeah. So it's all going well. But Louis is clearly a man of, well, of international ambition. So having conquered Britain in 1881, he decides he's going to go off and conquer America. So he goes with his wife and his family and they set off. And while he's out there, he serves as an agent for a company that's making that very kind of deeply embossed wallpaper that people loved in the late victorian period yeah so dense and textured and very heavy wallpaper yes and uh he also becomes the agent for a group of um french photographers who are out there so he's very much kind of you know keeping up with his photographic interests
里面放有一枚卢比、一份铁路指南、一本《惠特克年鉴》（Whitaker's Almanack）、一个婴儿奶瓶、各种其他东西、英国12位最美丽女性的照片，以及一张由路易和莎拉（Sarah）拍摄的维多利亚女王的照片。它就被放进去了。汤姆，我真的很喜欢时间胶囊这种东西。它们现在已经过时了，对吧？确实过时了。但它们是好东西。是的。路易和莎拉深深地参与其中，参与到这个令人兴奋的时间胶囊世界中。是的。所以一切进展顺利。但路易显然是一个有着国际野心的人。因此，在1881年征服英国后，他决定出发去征服美利坚。于是他带着妻子和家人出发了。当他在那里时，他担任了一家公司的代理商，该公司生产那种在维多利亚时代晚期备受人们喜爱的深度浮雕壁纸。是的，那种厚重、有质感且非常沉重的壁纸。是的。而且，他还成为了一群在那里的法国摄影师的代理商——所以他非常注重（你知道的）保持对摄影的兴趣。
and these are guys who are specializing in kind of panoramas of you know spectacular american vistas and also particularly of battlefield scenes so battle gettersburg that we think not that long after the civil war yeah so so that um and he because he he you know he's he's flogging his wallpaper keeping in with photographers and then he gets to palo Alto by Stanford in California. And there he sees photographs by a man called Edward Muybridge. Have you heard of him? Oh, yeah.
这些家伙专门拍摄各种壮丽美国景致的全景图，尤其是战场风貌的摄影——比如葛底斯堡战役（Gettysburg），我们认为那是内战结束后不久的事，对吧？是的。所以——由于他一直在兜售他的壁纸，与摄影师们保持联系——然后他来到了加利福尼亚州帕罗奥图的斯坦福大学。在那里，他看到了一个叫爱德华·迈布里奇（Edward Muybridge）的人拍摄的照片。你听说过他吗？哦，当然。
Very famous. So the pioneer of photography and horses. He was all about horses, Muybridge. Yes. He was originally called Edward Muggeridge. Yeah. And he changed it to Muybridge because he thought that that sounded more antique. And he changed his name, Edward Anglo-Saxon spelling yes he did yeah so it says Eadwood yeah and didn't he murder somebody he shot his he shot his wife's lover right and got acquitted because they said basically
非常著名。所以他是摄影和马匹的先驱。迈布里奇对马情有独钟。是的。他原本名叫爱德华·穆杰里奇（Edward Muggeridge）。是的。他把它改成了迈布里奇（Muybridge），因为他觉得这样听起来更古色古香。他还改了他的名字，爱德华的盎格鲁-萨克逊拼写——是的，他改了——所以写作Eadwood。而且他是不是谋杀过什么人？他枪杀了他妻子的情人，对吧？并且被判无罪，因为法庭基本上说——
said fair enough right so he's an interesting man yeah um yes exactly so he takes his photographs and it's kind of like umaccato. So you put them together and you get the sense of a horse galloping or a man running or whatever. And Leprince is obsessed by this. He becomes fascinated by it. And he starts to experiment with a camera that can shoot moving pictures. So rather than kind of take them individually, we'll shoot them and essentially create what we would call film, I guess. So taking multiple frames in quick succession. So he patents this camera, but we don't know if he ever managed to project the film that he'd taken. And even if he had, it probably wouldn't have worked because for reasons that I don't quite
说情有可原。好吧，所以他是个有趣的人。是的。——没错，所以他拍摄照片，有点像——呃——快板（staccato）。把它们拼凑起来，你就会有一种马在奔跑、人在奔跑之类动态的感觉。勒普兰斯对此着迷了。他对此深深着迷。他开始试验能够拍摄动态画面的摄像机。所以，与其说是单张拍摄，不如说是拍摄它们，本质上创造了我们今天所说的电影，我想。也就是在极短时间内拍摄多帧画面。所以他为这款摄像机申请了专利，但我们不知道他是否成功放映过他拍摄的电影。即使他成功了，它可能也不会成功，因为出于某些我不太理解的原因，
understand, the camera is taking it at different angles. So you wouldn't get the sense of a kind of continuous running film. It would be coming at you from different angles. So you wouldn't get the sense of a kind of continuous running film. It would be coming at you from different angles. It would look quite odd, I think. But definite sense that he's onto something, he's on the right track here. And so he realizes that actually the best place to develop this isn't America, but his father-in-law's factory back in Leeds. And so he goes back to England. He leaves his wife and children in America. He takes his eldest son, who by this point is a very able young boy called Adolf.
摄像机是从不同角度拍摄的。所以你不会获得一种连续放映电影的感觉。画面会从不同的角度向你袭来。所以你不会获得一种连续放映电影的感觉。画面会从不同的角度向你袭来。那样看起来会相当奇怪，我想。但可以肯定的是，他确有所获，他走在正确的轨道上。因此他意识到，实际上开发这个项目的最佳地点不是美国，而是他岳父在利兹的工厂。于是他回到了英格兰。他把妻子和孩子留在美国，只带上了长子——此时这个长子已经是一个非常能干的男孩，名叫阿道夫（Adolf）。
Oh, that's unfortunate. No, Adolf. Oh, Adolf. Adolf. You said Adolf. Well, because he's from Metz, isn't he, originally? So there's, you know. All right. Or maybe you're pronouncing it in a West Yorkshire way. Hey, Adolf. Adolf, you know. All right. Or maybe you're pronouncing it in a West Yorkshire way. Hey, Adolf.
哦，那可真不幸。不，阿道夫。哦，阿道夫。阿道夫。你刚才说的是阿道夫。嗯，因为他原本来自梅斯，不是吗？所以，你知道的。好吧。或者你可能是在用西约克郡的口音发音？嘿，阿道夫。阿道夫，你知道的。好吧。或者你可能是在用西约克郡的口音发音？嘿，阿道夫。
Adolf. Adolf. Adolf. Okay. I don't know what Adolf looked like, but I imagine that he wore a sailor suit. Almost certainly. But surely not when he was in Yorkshire.
阿道夫。阿道夫。阿道夫。好吧。我不知道阿道夫长什么样，但我猜他穿着水手服。几乎可以肯定。但他在约克郡时肯定不会穿。
Papa. Papa. Surely then he wore clogs. May I help you? And a flat cap. Hey, up. Come on, Adolf. So anyway, so Louis and Eddard and Joseph Whitley.
爸爸。爸爸。那他肯定穿着木屐。有什么需要我帮忙的吗？还戴着鸭舌帽。嘿，起来。来吧，阿道夫。总之，所以路易、埃达（Eddard，指Adolphe）和约瑟夫·惠特利——
Yeah. They're all piling in. Please do the whole thing in that accent. Do the rest of it in that accent. They're making camera. And Joseph Whitley's doing metal work. Actually, don't, don't,'t don't all right okay and le prince is working and working on his invention refining it making it better and better and better and by 1887 dominic yeah he is starting to shoot film
是的。他们全都一拥而上。请用那种口音说完整个节目。剩下的部分都用那种口音说。他们在制作摄像机。约瑟夫·惠特利在做金属加工。其实，别——别——别——好吧，好吧。勒普兰斯一直在工作，不断改进他的发明，让它变得越来越好。到了1887年，多米尼克，是的，他开始拍摄电影了。
up and as i've invented cinema hi anyway so i think that at this point we should take a break yeah and maybe we should in the break we should do all our accents and then come back and do it properly in the second half so we don't offend and horrify listeners. We will return. We will return, accent-free, with Adolphe, more Adventures of Adolphe after the break. I'm Marina Hyde.
——而且正如我所发明的电影一样，嗨。无论如何，我认为在这一点上我们应该休息一下。是的。也许在休息期间，我们应该把所有的口音都用一遍，然后在下半场以正常的口音回来，这样我们就不会冒犯和吓到听众了。我们会回来的。我们会回来的，不带任何口音，带着阿道夫，以及更多阿道夫的冒险故事，休息之后继续。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的机会，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The rest is history uh now pleasingly accent free at least i'm accent free tom are you accent free we very good continue please with the story of louis leprance inventor of cinema okay so we are in august 1887 and lepr Prince sends footage to his wife in New York, which is 16 frames of a man walking around a corner. Now, you may laugh, Dominic. You may laugh, but this is where it all begins. One minute you're doing that, the next it's Peter Jackson and the return of the king. Exactly. However, the problem for Louis is that he doesn't know whether it's worked or not.
欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。现在——令人欣慰的是——毫无口音，至少我没有口音。汤姆，你没有口音吗？我们非常好。请继续讲述电影发明者路易·勒普兰斯的故事吧。好的，所以我们正处于1887年8月，勒普兰斯将一段16帧、拍摄一个男人绕过街角的短片寄给了他在纽约的妻子。现在，你可能会笑，多米尼克。你可能会笑，但这正是一切开始的地方。上一分钟你还在拍这个，下一分钟就成了彼得·杰克逊（Peter Jackson）的《国王归来》。确实如此。然而，对路易来说，问题在于他不知道它是否成功了。
Oh. Because he doesn't have a projector. So he shot it on the camera, but he doesn't have a projector. What, there's no projector to be found in all of England? He hasn't invented it yet. Oh, he invents the projector. Well, he's got his camera,
哦。因为他没有放映机。所以他是用摄像机拍了下来，但他没有放映机。什么，全英格兰都找不到一台放映机吗？他还没发明出来呢。哦，他发明了放映机。嗯，他有了摄像机，
he's shooting this film, but he doesn't know whether it works because he doesn't have a projector. Okay, right. So it's unknown, but he's confident enough that he is on the right track that he applies for a u.s patent right and he is given this patent on on january the 10th 1888 it is patent number 376 247 and it is the method
他在拍摄这部电影，但他不知道它是否成功，因为他没有放映机。好吧，明白了。所以结果未知，但他有足够的信心认为自己走在正确的轨道上，于是他申请了美国专利。没错，他在1888年1月10日获得了这项专利。专利号是 376,247，这是一项用于制作动画画面的装置的方法。
of an apparatus for producing animated pictures. So there it is. It's commercially registered, set up, ready to go. If he can get it to a sufficient state that he can start making money out of it. And to do that, obviously he has to demonstrate that it works. By October of that year, so 1888, he is shooting film at a rate of about 12 to 16 pictures per minute. So he's upped the rate. And that October, he starts to take sequences of film that are incredibly, incredibly moving. You can see them. You can go on YouTube or whatever and look them up. So the first one,
所以就是这样。它已经完成了商业注册、组装完毕，随时准备投入使用了。如果他能将其推进到足以开始从中赚钱的阶段的话。而要做到这一点，他显然必须证明它是行之有效的。到那年10月，也就是1888年，他以每分钟大约12到16幅画面的速度拍摄电影。所以他提高了拍摄速率。同年10月，他开始拍摄令人难以置信的动态电影序列。你可以看到它们。你可以在YouTube或任何地方搜索并查看它们。所以第一段，
he goes to Oakwood Grange in Roundhay, which is an area in leeds and oakwood grange is the house of his parents-in-law so that's joseph and sarah whitley right so he goes there thank god he didn't invent sound tom they go out into garden and um there he films he just films a little scene oh so you see sarah his mother-in-law, she's dancing backwards and she turns around. And then you see Joseph and he's there and his coattails are flying as he turns around. And it's kind of incredible. This is where it's beginning. Adolphe is there as well.
他去了利兹奥克伍德（Roundhay）地区的奥克伍德格兰奇（Oakwood Grange），奥克伍德格兰奇是他岳父母的房子，也就是约瑟夫和莎拉·惠特利的家。没错，他去了那里。感谢上帝，他没有发明声音，汤姆。他们走到花园里，——在那里他拍摄，他只是拍摄了一个小场景。哦，所以你看到莎拉，他的岳母，她正在向后跳舞并转过身去。然后你看到约瑟夫，他也在那儿，当他转身时，他的燕尾服下摆随风飘扬。这简直难以置信。这就是一切开始的地方。阿道夫也在那里。
And a friend of Le Prince is called Annie Hartley. So they're all there. And this is where it all begins. He also films Adolphe playing his accordion. Listen to me play my accordion. So that's going on. And then he films traffic crossing a bridge in Leeds. So all of this is taken. Now, what is unclear is whether he has developed a projector that is sufficient to display this. And a lot kind of hangs on this because we're reaching the climax of the story. And there's a mystery around what happens to de la Prance that is, I suspect, very strongly connected to the fact of whether he had developed the projector or not so over um 1889 to 90 he's working with a mechanic in uh in leeds called james longley
勒普兰斯的一位朋友叫安妮·哈特利（Annie Hartley）。所以他们都在那里。这就是一切开始的地方。他还拍摄了阿道夫拉手风琴的画面。听我拉手风琴。这一切都在进行中。然后他拍摄了利兹一座桥上的车流。所有这些都被拍摄下来了。现在，不清楚的是他是否开发出了一台足以播放这些画面的放映机。很多事情都悬而未决，因为我们正在接近故事的高潮。关于德拉普兰斯（Le Prince）身上发生了什么，存在一个谜团，我怀疑这与他是否研发出放映机有着非常紧密的联系。所以从1889年到1890年，他一直在与利兹的一位机械师合作，
and they're they're working on what they call deliverers what we would call projectors right louis leprance seems to have reached a kind of a he's he's either decided that it is going to work or it's not going to work well Well, that's narrowed it down. I know it has. Evidence for the fact that he thinks it is going to work. In 1889, he takes American citizenship to go with his French citizenship. Because he wants to establish himself in America. He wants to go and establish himself in America.
名叫詹姆斯·朗利（James Longley）。他们正在研发他们所称的deliverers（交付器，发音误传/误听，实际应指放映机），也就是我们所说的放映机。好吧，路易·勒普兰斯似乎达到了一个瓶颈——他要么已经决定这行得通，要么行不通。好吧，这可真是把范围缩小了。我知道是的。有证据表明他认为这行得通。1889年，他获得了美国国籍，以搭配他的法国国籍。因为他想在美国建立自己的事业。他想去美国建立自己的事业。
Late 1890, he's planning to sail to America and join his wife there. Yeah. But before he does that, he goes back to France to see his brother. So he goes to Paris. He goes to Dijon, which is where his brother is. On the 16th of September, he's due to take a train back to Paris where he's going to be met by three of his friends. He misses that train. His brother says that he then helped Louis onto the next train right the train went off and louis is never seen again he's never seen again he vanishes completely crikey and body never found well there is a police search they find no trace of him whatsoever and there are no leads at all to follow he it's as
1890年底，他计划乘船去美国与妻子团聚。是的。但在那之前，他回到法国去看望他的兄弟。所以他去了巴黎。他去了第戎（Dijon），他的兄弟就在那里。9月16日，他本应搭乘火车返回巴黎，他的三个朋友将在那里接他。他错过了那趟火车。他兄弟说，他随后帮路易上了下一趟火车——对，火车开走了，而路易就再也没有出现过。他再也没有出现过。他彻底消失了。天哪，连尸体都没找到。嗯，警方进行了搜查，完全没有找到他的踪迹，也没有任何线索可循。他就像
though he's vanished off the face of the earth and so the question then obviously is well what happened to him and there are various theories and the most popular theory which was pushed by uh louis leprance's wife is that louis leprance had got his projector going he'd got his film he'd got his patent he'd got his American citizenship. He was coming back to America and he was going to premiere his invention and his work in New York. And this would establish him clearly as the father of cine film. The person who does establish himself as the father of the moving camera is Thomas Edison, who was a notoriously horrible man, incredibly jealous of his own work, ever ready to get rid of competitors.
人间蒸发了一样。所以，显而易见的问题是：他究竟发生了什么？有各种各样的理论，其中最受欢迎的理论是由路易·勒普兰斯的妻子提出的，即路易·勒普兰斯已经成功造出了放映机，拍好了电影，拿到了专利，获得了美国国籍。他正准备回到美国，在纽约首映他的发明和作品。这将使他明确确立为电影胶片之父的地位。而真正确立自己为动态摄像机之父的人是托马斯·爱迪生（Thomas Edison），他是一个出了名的讨厌鬼，对自己的工作极其嫉妒，随时准备除掉竞争对手。
And Edison demonstrates that cinematography works the year after Le Prince dies, or vanishes, or whatever happens to him. So he does that in May 1891. And theory is is that perhaps edison or people working with edison wanted to nobble the prance who knows what happened maybe they got rid of him but would edison's reach extend to the trains between where was it paris and dijon yeah well uh so in 1898 um edison sues an american company and he does so on the basis that he is the sole inventor of cinematography, that no one else has developed it. And the American company that's being sued call Adolf as a witness for defense, for their defense.
爱迪生在勒普兰斯去世、失踪或发生其他事情的第二年，就展示了电影摄影技术确实可行。所以他在1891年5月做到了这一点。这个理论认为，也许爱迪生或与爱迪生合作的人想要除掉勒普兰斯——谁知道发生了什么呢？也许他们除掉了他。但爱迪生的手能伸到——那是哪里来着？——巴黎和第戎之间的火车上吗？是的。所以——在1898年，嗯，爱迪生起诉了一家美国公司，他的起诉依据是他是电影摄影技术的唯一发明者，没有其他人开发过它。被起诉的美国公司请来阿道夫作为辩方证人，为他们的案件进行辩护。
And Adolf says, yes, he insists that his father had invented it. Edison wins. And although that verdict is subsequently overturned, it's enough to establish him absolutely clearly as the father of cinematography. And Laplace's widow is incredibly bitter about it. And basically says, she very, very strongly implies that Edison was responsible for her husband's disappearance. So we don't know. I mean i agree it's i don't think it's very likely other theories yeah that he was murdered by his brother you know who he'd come to visit who he'd come to visit well i mean so in cases of murder people the police invariably look at family
阿道夫说，是的，他坚称他的父亲发明了它。爱迪生赢了。尽管这一判决后来被推翻了，但它足以绝对明确地确立爱迪生作为电影摄影之父的地位。勒普兰斯的遗孀对此感到极其痛苦。她基本上说——她非常强烈地暗示爱迪生应对她丈夫的失踪负责。所以我们不知道。我的意思是，我同意——我觉得这不太可能。其他理论呢？——比如他被他前去拜访的兄弟谋杀了。你懂的，他去拜访的兄弟。嗯，在谋杀案中，警方通常会调查家庭
members don't they and uh the brother was the last person to see him alive supposedly so perhaps didn't put him on the train at all he's the only person who vouches for the fact he put him on the train. So yeah, so that's a possibility. So why would his brother kill him? Perhaps there was, I don't know, there was some will or something like that. Nobody's ever been able to find a motive that would explain that. But I guess, again, that's possible. Another theory is that Louis Le Prince was gay and that he negotiated a kind of a divorce and he agreed that he would vanish to spare the family the shame of having a homosexual father or husband. It seems unlikely that he would have abandoned his cinematographical interests. That is definitely an argument against it. And the other argument is that there is absolutely
成员，对吧？而且他的兄弟据称是最后一个见到他活著的人。所以也许他根本就没有送他上火车。他是唯一一个担保他上了火车的人。所以，是的，这是一种可能。那么他的兄弟为什么要杀他呢？也许有——我不知道，有什么遗嘱之类的东西。从来没有人能找到一个能够解释这一点的动机。但我想，这同样是可能的。另一个理论是，路易·勒普兰斯是个同性恋，他协商了一种离婚，并同意自己凭空消失，以免家人承担拥有一个同性恋父亲或丈夫的耻辱。他抛弃自己的电影摄影事业，这似乎不太可能。这绝对是一个反驳的论点。另一个论点是，绝对
no evidence whatsoever that he was gay. So it's just completely invented. It's completely invented. The fourth suggestion is that he commits suicide. And really for that to make sense, he has to feel that his business isn't going to work. He has to probably have felt that he hadn't developed the film, that it hadn't worked. He couldn't get his projector. Perhaps he went to see his brother to borrow money, to raise capital, to develop it a little bit further. And sustaining that argument is the fact that in 2003, a photo was found in the Paris archives of a man who had been pulled from the Seine in 1890, who looks quite like le prince people have argued that the the man in the photograph is too
没有任何证据表明他是同性恋。所以这完全是凭空捏造的。完全是凭空捏造的。第四种说法是他自杀身亡。要让这种说法说得通，他必须觉得他的生意行不通。他可能觉得他没有成功研发出电影，根本行不通。他找不到放映机。也许他去看望他的兄弟是为了借钱、筹集资金，以便进一步开发它。支持这一论点的依据是，在2003年，人们在巴黎档案馆里发现了一张照片，照片上是一个于1890年从塞纳河中打捞上来的男子，他长得很像勒普兰斯。人们争辩说，照片中的男子太
short he's not le prince was a very i said he's a very large man that doesn't seem to correspond to that so again the the the jury is out on that but we don't know you know it's still unproven um we don't know what happened to le prince and And the tragedy of the story is that because he dies, having invented this film, but it never gets shown. And it may well be that Le Prince died not knowing or thinking that he hadn't been able to develop it. He'd never seen his own films. Well, we don't know. There are people who say that he did,
矮了，他不是勒普兰斯——我刚才说过，他身材非常高大。这似乎对不上号。所以，关于这一点，陪审团依然没有定论，但我们不知道——你知道的，这仍然未经证实。我们不知道勒普兰斯身上发生了什么。这个故事的悲剧在于，由于他带着这项已经发明出来的电影技术死去，但它却从未被播放过。很有可能勒普兰斯在去世时并不知道，或者以为自己没能成功研发出它。他从未看过自己的电影。嗯，我们不知道。有些人说他看过，
that they developed a projector in Leeds and he showed it to some of his family. But this is contested. But it's possible, I would say likely, that he didn't yeah and it may well be that he died thinking that he'd been a failure and it was only kind of several decades later that finally they were able to to put this film into a projector and show that he had you know he had done it he had got there and so that film of um his father-in-law and mother-in-law and friend and son in the garden in Leeds, and his son playing the accordion and the traffic
说他们在利兹研发出了一台放映机，他把它放给了一些家人看。但这受到了质疑。不过，这是可能的，我会说很有可能他并没有看过——而且很有可能他在临终时认为自己是个失败者。直到几十年后，人们才终于能够把这段胶片放进放映机，证明了他确实做到了，他成功了。所以，关于他在利兹花园里的岳父、岳母、朋友和儿子的那段胶片，以及他的儿子拉手风琴和利兹桥上车流的画面，
going over the bridge in Leeds, these are monuments to the history of film, but they're also monuments to the ghostly legacy of this extraordinary man who really should be better known than he is. So with such an amazing story, why is he not better known? Because he dies and because his film is only seen much, much later. He's written out of the early drafts of the story of film. And so Edison takes the starring role. Yeah, the early drafts, they sort of fall into two categories, don't they? They're either American or they're French.
这些都是电影史上的丰碑，但它们也是这位非凡之人的幽灵遗产的丰碑。他本该比现在更出名。既然有这样一个精彩的故事，为什么他没有变得更出名呢？因为他去世了，而且他的电影直到很久很久以后才被人看到。他在电影史早期草案中被除名了。因此爱迪生占据了主角地位。是的，早期的草案，它们大致分为两类，对吧？它们要么是美国式的，也就是爱迪生以及好莱坞的发展；
So they're either Edison and then the development of Hollywood, or they're Georges Méliès and then the tradition of French cinema, I suppose. But he doesn't quite fit, I suppose, because he's moving between Britain, France, and Britain and America. What an interesting story. It is an interesting story, isn't it? Those clips I've just looked at, actually, they are on YouTube, Tom. I mean, they're very short, aren't they? They're short, but they are ghostly, as you say. Yeah. It does seem like you're looking at kind of ghosts. Yes. And in
要么是乔治·梅里爱（Georges Méliès）以及法国电影传统，我想。但他似乎不太符合，因为他在英国、法国、英国和美国之间辗转。多么有趣的故事。这真是一个有趣的故事，不是吗？我刚才看的那几个片段，其实它们就在YouTube上，汤姆。我是说，它们非常短，对吧？它们很短，但正如你所说，它们带着一种幽灵般的色彩。是的。感觉你好像在看某种幽灵。是的。从
a sense, you're looking at the ghosts of Le Prince's career and fame. Yeah. Very moving, I think. Tom, I think you should, you're a great campaigner. You should start a new campaign for recognition in Leeds. He's commemorated in Leeds. I think there's a plaque. Right. So the garden where the first film was shot got demolished. But I think there's a plaque on the spot commemorating it.
某种意义上说，你看到的是勒普兰斯的职业生涯和名誉的幽灵。是的，非常感人，我想。汤姆，我觉得你应该——你是个伟大的倡导者——你应该在利兹发起一项认可他的新运动。他在利兹得到了纪念。我想那里有一块牌匾。对。所以拍摄第一部电影的花园已经被拆毁了。但我认为现场有一块牌匾纪念它。
Le Prince is remembered in Leeds. And I think there was a film that was made about him a few years ago. So he is remembered. But I think, you know, this series is all about resurrecting people who perhaps wouldn't have their own podcast under normal circumstances. So I commend Louis LaPrance. To you, Dominic, and to the listeners. Tom, you've persuaded me. I think some sort of biopic with him and Edison as the villain.
利兹人记得勒普兰斯。而且几年前好像还拍过一部关于他的电影。所以他是被人们铭记的。但我认为，你知道，这个系列就是为了让那些在正常情况下可能不会有自己播客的人复活。所以我向你、多米尼克以及听众们推荐路易·勒普兰斯。汤姆，你说服我了。我觉得应该拍一部传记片，他和爱迪生作为大反派。
Yes. Edison played by, who would play Edison, Tom? Oh, that cannibal guy. Hannibal? The guy who got cancelled for being a cannibal. Oh, my word. Armie Hammer. Armie Hammer.
是的。爱迪生由谁来扮演呢，汤姆？哦，那个食人族家伙。汉尼拔？那个因为当食人族而被取消资格的家伙。哦，天哪。艾米·汉莫（Armie Hammer）。艾米·汉莫。
Armie Hammer as Thomas Edison. You're offering him a way back. Yes. And who's playing Louis Le Prince? Louis Le Prince? I don't know. Someone who can do both Yorkshire and French. Yes.
艾米·汉莫饰演托马斯·爱迪生。你这是在给他提供一条复出的路。是的。那谁来演路易·勒普兰斯？路易·勒普兰斯？我不知道。一个既能说约克郡口音又能说法国口音的人。是的。
Sean Bean. Brilliant. Perfect. Well, sean sean bean always dies sean bean he does always die sean bean would do it superbly uh he's had a lot of interactions with the french and sharp so he can draw on that draw on that when he does his accent uh brilliant uh so that you can file that alongside the blind beak our um great unmade netflix series among the many moving pictures that we ought to have made tom oh and we may yet when we diversify out of the podcast business exactly right so uh thank you very much for listening um merci a toi tom for that fantastic story how do you do and uh we shall see you all next time.
肖恩·宾（Sean Bean）。太棒了。完美。嗯，肖恩·宾总是死，肖恩·宾——他确实总是死。肖恩·宾会演得极其出色。他在《夏普》（Sharpe，译者注：肖恩·宾主演的历史剧）中跟法国人有很多互动，所以当他说口音时可以借鉴那些经验——借鉴那些经验——太棒了。所以你可以把这个和我们的“盲嘴子”（The Blind Beak，指前文提到的虚构未拍摄项目）归档在一起，那是我们众多未拍摄的网飞系列之一，在我们本该制作的众多动态影像中，汤姆，哦，当我们从播客业务中多元化发展时，我们可能还会去拍呢。完全正确。非常感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，汤姆，带来这个精彩的故事。你好吗？我们下次再见。
Bye-bye. Au revoir. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
拜拜。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听加更节目、提前获取内容、无广告音频以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝娱乐八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的机会，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。